oh hello guess what I am in right now
traffic
it's a beautiful Channel um I just
wanted to say hello because I haven't
put a video on this channel in a long
time and this channel is a secret
Orion secret sort of um so I'm driving
that's fun
alright any of you driving and watching
this right now stop it
focus on driving what's happening what
is today today is Wednesday there we got
it yeah they're um
it's Wednesday it's twelve twelve twelve
which I thought was the end of the world
it's not 12-21-12 very confusing Mayans
the tricky business what if like one
Mayan really wanted twelve twelve twelve
to be the end of the world but they made
like a typo when they were carved into
the rock and they carved 12-21-12 and
then they were like ah [ __ ]
well I guess that's gonna be the day
think about that chew on that with the
brain teeth okay just saying hey now I
should go and keep driving because I
have to get to a destination
and surprise surprise probably gonna be
late we you alright have a wonderful day
maybe it is the end of the world who
knows who knows you just get water and
any crisis situation you always need to
have water so I've heard
so do that I'm just scrambling still
thought this was going to be over by now
it's not still going
and now it's over